foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
George Campbell Ramsey personality
co-host of the smart money happy hour
with Rachel Cruz a production of Ramsey
networks is my co-host today we're glad
you're here we're here to answer your
life and your money questions phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Cecilia
is in Atlanta to start off this hour hi
Cecilia how are you
hey Dave I'm great thanks good how can
we help
so I'm interested in whether or not I
should Leverage
equity lines for more property
when I've tried to not have debt
and is that safe
for investment property activity
okay you realize your sentences just ran
against each other right I mean okay
that's possible I don't want any debt
should I go into debt
no I mean that was what you just told me
I'm confused okay okay
based on there are many
many
buying homes and then getting lines of
equity to buy additional homes as
investment properties and then they have
this whole domino
of yeah their equity lines being leaning
on other properties I I think it's been
spending a lot of time on Tick Tock
haven't you
no I'm a realtor and I I hear other I
hear other people
say yeah so I honestly how long have you
been a realtor
five years I love it
um good so I I know that you kind of had
a history of being in real estate and
not not eventually being good for you
and so I don't know if you're firm on
that or it's the current real estate has
been great to me borrowing on real
estate about destroyed me
so what I did as I got caught up in the
same kind of crap that's floating around
out there right now it was happening in
the early 80s only it was a different
world obviously we didn't have the
internet instead we had these wonderful
things called infomercials where some
goober is sitting by the surf selling
tapes and a three thousand dollar
weekend course on how to buy real estate
nothing down it was the exact same crap
as all over the place right now
especially on tick tock tick tock's got
a real version of it going okay borrow
all you can because real estate's always
awesome you're always going to make
money it's passive income says the get
rich quick gurus okay now I did that I
started from nothing I was 22 years old
I got four million dollars worth of real
estate by the time I was 26 over a
million dollar net worth meaning I owed
3 million on four million dollars that's
not a bad Equity position at all I had a
lot of short-term notes because I was
doing flips before there was Chip and
Joanna to tell us how
and um so I actually did it I've owned
over 2 000 pieces of property in my life
so I'm not inexperienced at this and uh
the bank got scared and called our notes
the Second Bank got when we were in
trouble and called our notes and I had
nine I had 120 days to come up with a
million too and it was all in real
estate and I had no cash because I
believed in leverage because that's what
I had been taught by the get rich quick
people does that any of that sound
familiar
um yes and I haven't bought it but I I
have clients and I don't want to
counsel them incorrectly yeah sure
here's the thing so here let me tell you
the end of the story and and then I'll
tell you my answer and so you understand
the why to my answer okay in the story
was I went broke I spent two and a half
years of my life losing everything I
owned one year I made 250 000 at 27
years old the next year I'm my taxable
income was six thousand dollars I spent
the whole year selling everything to
keep it from being foreclosed on still
some of it got foreclosed on and at the
end of the day two and a half years
later I was bankrupt because they called
her because they were coming to take the
baby furniture out of my house and I was
done with them okay now that's the end
of my story however the other part of
the story was there was a guy named
Robert Allen who would have been on Tick
Tock today if he were still a thing he
wrote a book called nothing down and he
famously would be dropped into any City
without his wallet and buy a house with
no identification or credit of any kind
within 48 hours there's a goober out
there or two doing that on Tick Tock
right now modeling after after him okay
and so he would do this I remember
watching him do it in Chicago he did 48
Hours he bought three houses nothing
down okay and he did this his next book
was called creating wealth he went all
over America starting real estate clubs
called acre and each of these clubs were
to feed him leads to buy more real
estate nothing down I was in one of
those clubs because I was buying nothing
down a bunch of us there was ended up
being 160 people in our investing Club
later Robert Allen filed chapter 11
bankruptcy the whole thing caught up and
took him out too but anyway
of the guys 130 of them or so in that
club
uh now 30 years ago the number of them
that did not that still own any rental
real estate is about six the rest of
them have gone broke the six that still
own it paid it off and got out of debt
they did not get rich doing this crap
no one makes it a decade doing this crap
it's crap don't do it was that unclear
very clear
you walked into it didn't you Cecilia
answer this question I'm curious what is
driving you toward this are you doing
are you not great financially
no I I took a little course called
Financial Freedom Financial uh Peace
University and I got debt free paid off
my mortgage paid off my children's
student loans with my husband now but
what's making you just all the people
doing it that are wanting you to do this
uh no I'm trying I have very much
ignored all the all that clamor
um so I I did when I diversify my
portfolio until you asked me a question
about leveraging lines of credit to go
by real estate you ignored it
well I'm that's why I'm talking to you
is because I haven't done anything
foolish I know I know but I'm just
saying plan on it yeah who who what was
it that made you think that that was
even a good idea
that's what George was asking well I I
guess my question was had something
changed in the world
's Finance no nothing changes
get around stuff you know my my dad
lived some of what you're talking about
as well he bought you know land he
couldn't afford and
um hope to hold on to it thinking it's
gonna
turn around and I'm going to make the
zoodles on it because a builder is going
to want it and 20 years later that had
not yet happened he died before he saw
yeah any of that happen
so I will tell you the other part of the
end of the story The the end of the end
of the end of the story
um I after I went broke we started uh
saving money and investing and I used
some of that money to buy a piece of
real estate cash and they then I used
some of that income to buy another piece
of real estate cash and then in 2008
when everything Dove down I had a big
pile of cash and I bought a bunch of
stuff for 15 cents on the dollar today I
own
probably 45 500 million dollars worth of
real estate it's all paid for and I
never borrowed a dime on any of it they
ain't taking this one
this one's mine me and God were managing
this no Bankers involved this is the
Ramsay show
thank you
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
guarantee and
and free see whyblinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
to learn all of life's lessons the hard
way
you can choose to watch other people be
idiots and not do what they did
so I could be the sample idiot that
doesn't have to so you don't have to go
buy a bunch of nothing down real estate
and then George can live a proper life
and you know buy his first house very
conservatively sell it buy another house
pay it off and uh by 32 be a millionaire
with zero debt and never had you don't
have to you don't have to go through
drug rehab to have a testimony to decide
to not do drugs
it's also true me I have to do
everything the hard way but you guys can
learn from me because I have a PhD in
Dumb and you did it very publicly Dave
most people do it in private you chose
to broadcast it it's worse than that I
made it into a brand
I made my stupidity into a brand is that
the guy involved for bankruptcy
bankruptcy and tells people how to get
out of debt what kind of dumb butt is
that well one that knows the track
record but knows what it's like you know
I mean one that's touched the hot stove
that's trying to warn others I can just
you know I can you don't have to teach
get grab your kid's hand put it up there
you know you just don't don't touch it I
did it once it's not good for you well I
think the heart of it is people are
feeling desperate with the economy and
inflation I'll never build wealth and so
they start taking shortcuts and fear
greed and pride kick in a little bit and
all of a sudden they make some risky
decisions and the risk meter gets broken
or they put it aside and decide I'm
gonna be the exception to the rule I
know what Dave says but I saw it work
out on a guy on Tick Tock so therefore
it's gonna work out for me yeah it's um
I suck other day cities
his uh 11 year old had a um
oh God he had this whole thing that was
completely illegal built out I know wow
well I mean he was funding Roth IRAs and
they didn't have any earned income oh
I've seen this one yeah and it's some
kind of like tax hack and you can give
your kids income my four-year-old works
for me full time and I pay them sixty
thousand dollars a year and they're and
I'm funding uh uh that's illegal the IRS
is about to be on your butt yeah when
you get audited you will have like the
capital L on your forehead thing this
says Loser yeah that's what will happen
oh my God you people so no you you hit
you hit it though it's the trifecta uh
and I have done all three uh and all
three will make you broke greed
fear
and pride
see pride is I buy a car to impress
someone at a stoplight that I will never
meet
it's like a Christmas Vacation good
looking girl waving at Chevy Chase and
he wrecks his whole family's car right
it's that that's your deal you remember
that oh that's such a great it's a
classic scene was it Christy Brinkley I
think so I think so I rewatched it
recently yeah the audience has given me
a a nod so a trivial Pursuits got it
okay the uh uh and so that that's Pride
you know and I've done that one when you
buy crap and Rachel's thing she posted
and you've talked you wrote about it in
your new book that we haven't oh we
haven't tell anybody the secret I just
finished the mass the manuscript last
week is really good but the uh as you
talked about in that she said if would I
buy this if no one ever saw it oh yeah
that's your test on the pride button
right it's a gut check the war greed
greed is not like
it's not like you know Simon Legree and
scroogey Scrooge McDuck and I'm stacking
coins in the cave that's not greed
greed is I'm just Money Motivated to the
exclusion of other things that are
healthy
you can have a money motivation and not
and not being excluded to the exclusion
of other things but if you're only if
you're only button to push is money
that's great and you're always going to
step in the do when you do that and the
third one I love you said is desperate
that's the worst one God that one right
there man I the other two I got over the
other two by the time I was like 27 28
years old that that desperate one that
will really come that's when people you
know
I'm gonna take the trip to Vegas and
I'll hit and that'll save my business
that's you know when you get desperate
just about 20 seconds later after I get
desperate I get stupid and right after I
get stupid I get broke right I mean it's
true that's an aggressive causal thing
it desperate leads to stupid leads to
broke when you go oh I've got it's the
only way it's my only that you're about
to screw up when you get in your drama
queen gets to kicking in you're about to
screw up but they heard that one story
of that guy who went to Vegas and it was
on the line and he did it and he doubled
his money and said and saved the win
save the business yeah I've read a
couple of business books where the guy
says you know if I was down I couldn't
make payroll on Friday so I went to
Vegas on Wednesday and I made payroll
and now I'm such and such I've heard
that I don't know if they're true but I
you know they make for a great reason
let me just tell you it's not a good
business it's not business practice it's
not life practice it's not a life hack
it's just straight up stupidity that
somebody got away with you know well
somebody's got to win the house wins
brother the house wins look at the side
look at the quality of their furniture
and light fixtures better than yours
okay the house wins they have more
lights and dinghies than you do there's
a reason they took your money and they
took fools like yours money before you
got there that's how they got that the
house wins sports betting is hilarious
people that don't understand statistics
Sports bet that have you never had a
class in statistics if you took a class
in statistics you'd understand where the
bookie wins you understand why people
there's how they pay for duber with the
gold necklace that was a Caesars oh yeah
the Caesars commercials that guy man how
do you pay that guy and you pay all that
production and you know what their what
their budget is for a jillion dollars
for Caesars for sports betting and where
do they get the money for that you
America oh hello are you thinking you're
gonna get on FanDuel and MGM Sports and
make 20 bucks FanDuel is not about fans
dueling it's about you losing your
fanduel's making bank as serious money
it's all off of you because they
understand statistics hello
probability probability of a win and and
you don't beat the odds after you play a
while
you occasionally do and that's what
keeps the fools coming back just like my
golf game there you go all right open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five one good shot out
of 72 and you keep playing the same
stupid game over and over that's how
personal that was personal it's just
there's too much authenticity in this
segment all right Jim is in Tulsa hey
Jim how are you
I am doing good nice to talk to you you
too how can we help
yes sir uh I have a what would Dave do
in my shoes uh at age 62 I have uh been
divorced four years and four months I'm
pretty much a divorce that just
basically left me pretty much on the
Street Homeless uh I've been living with
a family member in a one-room house uh
of one room in a house and
um
I have been basically getting on your
plan since then I'm having to pay child
support alimony
and trying to get my life back in order
and have been on your plan
pretty much intense up until uh just
last week uh I have
accumulated uh quite a bit of wealth and
I'm just trying to get an idea in moving
into uh whoa whoa whoa whoa you drove by
being on the street to accumulated
wealth like nothing just happened what
happened okay well in intense I have
been saving basically my budget plan
since I've been living
you know since divorce has been
basically
spending one dollar for every two
dollars I'd save
and at this point on closing last Friday
I was worth 1.158 million
you did that in four years from the
street
yes sir yes sir why are you still living
in the relative's house in one but in
one room
that's a little strange my question to
you yes it is strange but I'm just
trying to get back on my feet yeah I
think you're back online you think I'm
ready you're a millionaire I think
you're back on your feet I don't know if
you're emotionally back on your feet but
I think you're financially back on your
feet dude it sounds like you got run
over by a truck emotionally
I'm sorry it's obvious you were hurt
really really bad and you're still
reeling from that and still took some of
your confidence
it sounds like you've done an incredible
job with the money piece of this so I'd
go buy me a little house man I think
it's time this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show George
Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host y'all should be here at the
breaks they're more entertaining than
the show all right the stuff you don't
get to hear yeah Brittany is with us in
St Louis hey Brittany how are you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
so I just paid off nine thousand dollars
with a credit card debt and I
have on credit card debt free now and
um I have downloaded your every dollar
budgeting app I'm trying a new way and
trying to get like on a complete full
budget not just like knowing what's in
my account and stuff and I bought the
premium version of your app and I'm kind
of wondering because I'm trying to get
out of living paycheck to paycheck and
I've accounted for everything that I put
into savings and then all of my bills
and then my last step which is my car
um I have accounted for all of that in
like groceries and all of that but where
do you put because it's a zero based
budget so where do you put the money
that you don't plan to spend at all like
the buffer that's in your checking
account that you roll over like every
week or every month so you're saying you
went under in some categories on your
budget giving you extra than you planned
for
basically yes so you didn't spend every
dollar
or you're saying or you're saying the
money that you're setting aside in a
sinking fund what do you do with that
I'm
so how much money did you start your
month with on this budget
it's about 3 800. okay it's every one of
the 3 800 have a name
no I'm I have like about 200 left
that's what I was after so if you got
money left while you're still creating
the budget that's going to go toward
your next baby step which for you is
this car debt right
right it sounds like it does happen if
you've got 200 left at the end of the
budget that you're going to go back to
your car debt and add 200 extra payment
okay any money you can squeeze out of
your budget goes under debt snowball
until you're done with baby step two
and that 200 is what you squeezed out of
your budget by managing well you are
cool how does it feel to be large and in
charge
I'm excited yeah I want to be weird I
don't want to be normal anymore tell
people what it feels like Brittany
because I know we were messaging on
Instagram I said hey call the show so we
can dig into the details but how does it
feel to actually pay attention to your
money and plan for it instead of just
see where it went with one of these
tracking apps that are out there does it
give you peace and confidence for the
future
I mean because I am I
I've only been I've literally came from
not even writing anything down at a
register to like basically to your app
so
um
and the other side of this if you let's
say you you budgeted 150 bucks for
groceries you spent 120. and so you got
30 bucks left over that might be sitting
in your checking account and you can
then roll that over to the debt and then
attack it even more if you can you know
if any of your budget items come in
under at the end of the month that
should give you the extra cash agreed
yes that's what George is saying throw
that at the debt too but right now we
know there's 200 and something now in
addition to that separate subject not
the 3800 but just keep a running balance
in your checking account that's
different this is your every dollar is
not your checking account every dollar
is what you're doing with this month's
income
okay okay there's a difference because
you could you could keep 200 in your
checking account but that doesn't or 800
in your checking account or four dollars
in your checking account but that
doesn't enter into the 3800 discussion
if you let's say you started the month
with 207 dollars in your checking
account okay
and you had 3 800 come in and thirty
eight hundred dollars go out but with
your every dollar budget then that means
you would still have two hundred and
seven dollars left in your checking
account so you can keep a pad a little
pad in there and you should actually end
the checking account does that make
sense to you
right yeah because that's what I was
wondering you know like when the debt
when the car
s then what will be your next baby step
the emergency fund we're going to add to
the 1 000 account until it's up to three
to six months of expenses so how much is
your car payment
452 okay and if you had a month like
this month you have 652 going against
the car right
okay so you put 652 in your baby step
three
and your your 1000 became 1652 and then
the next month it's uh
2300 and 4.
follow me
assuming the numbers stayed exactly the
same which they never do exactly the
same but right but um but I mean
whatever you squeeze you can get out of
this out of this you put the squeeze on
the baby step that's what George was
saying and that's the beauty of the
every dollar app because now you're
telling your money what to do instead of
wondering where it went how old are you
I'm 30. oh you were gonna be so rich
what do you make
I make about 50 Grand a year right now
but I just got a promotion at my job and
it will probably start after the first
of the year and I don't know what my
compensation is going to be yet for that
but more that is awesome it's only going
to accelerate your baby steps yeah and
Brittany go to everydollar.com budgeting
our friend Rachel Cruz is doing a free
webinar uh three days from now August
24th so tune in for that make sure you
sign up and all of you listening go
check that out Rachel's going to walk
you through how to set up an every
dollar budget and it's not going to be
boring because it's Rachel she makes
everything fun
you may not know what happened but
you'll be laughing no I mean you'll know
what happened it's great and uh she uh
but she's going to cover the irregular
income and the also how the baby steps
work with every dollar a little bit a
little bit of what we're talking about
just now but probably in a whole lot
more detail on this webinar it's all
free by the way
so where'd you say we go everydollar.com
budgeting okay and that's to sign up for
Rachel's free webinar I was trying to
remember what it was and I was looking
around I know it's written around down
here somewhere but I knew you would know
it absolutely I love a good link now and
you're going to be doing some of those
after the baby comes right that's right
in September I'll be doing a few of
these so I can't beat Rachel but if you
want me you know you can settle oh
you'll get the uh listen Rachel's funny
Georgia's got the snark you don't want
to miss the snark if that's your speed
when we have snark and budgeting
together we have a masterpiece you're
gonna love it wow you're gonna love it
Jason is in Boston hey Jason welcome to
the Ramsay show Millennials hello thank
you hey what's up man thank you very
much nice to uh thanks for taking the
call sure
um
so my question is I am saving for a
house right now
and I have some other debts that I
believe are healthy debts that I'm
wondering if I should pay off before
you know saving and saving up money for
the house
um to elaborate on that a little bit
just some things here
um right now
I am saving 25
of every paycheck
how much other debt do you have
so the debt that I have is I owe 36 000
on my car
and then I have a mortgage
for a condominium that comes to about
now the mortgage I'm not living there
I'm renting that out
um and you know the tenant lives there
and you know that was my first little
property now I'm living with my fiance
in her condo and my car payment is 7.75
a month
however the interest rate on that is
1.99
and as far as finances go
I have about a solid three months of
living expenses
what do you make
uh my salary from my job is one hundred
thousand dollars a year and then I I do
make
um
uh rental income from my condo yeah and
how old are you
I am 37. okay I'll tell you what when
you come back from this break we will um
I'll tell you what we would do in your
situation
which is basically nothing you're doing
this
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
now
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host Today Jason is with us in Boston
he and his fiancee are saving up for
another house he's got a condo worth
about 900k that he rents out 775 car
payment at one point whatever percent uh
makes 100K and uh was wondering about uh
whether you got to pay off the car or
not or be saving for a house and that's
about how far we got in the discussion
is that a fair summary of what you told
me sir
yeah that's a fair summary okay the
condo is not worth 900k though the con
it's a small condo oh I'm sure you're
paying 900 a month on the mortgage
correct oh I misunderstood what's the
condo worth
the condo I bought it for 150 and it's
currently worth 230.
what do you owe on it
121. okay that's what I'm after okay
cool I misunderstood I apologize and
your goal now is to get a primary
residence
that is correct for you guys to live in
you have any cash
do I have any cash yes in my bank I have
three months of emergency savings and
then I keep one month of operating
expenses in my checking how much is that
all that together
um it's about 18 000 in my savings and
it is about
six
in my checking account okay we'll call
it 24. okay
now in addition to that money I have
twenty five thousand dollars saved up
for the down payment of a house and
what's the balance out on the car
thirty six thousand dollars you told me
that earlier okay all right good so you
have the cash to pay this car off but
you told us at the beginning of the call
that you want to keep it around because
it's a healthy debt
you know the interest is 1.99
and I feel like
I am making a lot more than that on you
know wherever I'm investing this twenty
five thousand dollars so you have thirty
six thousand dollars
at 1.99 right yeah and this or two we'll
call it and you you're 25 000 is sitting
at what interest rate
um anywhere from six to eleven your cash
is sitting at six to eleven
yeah right now
um
yes that is correct where 211.
so
um I use a credit union that's giving me
a fantastic interest rate is this a CD
or something
you're not you're not getting anywhere
near close to 11 on that 25 dude you're
talking about something that mattered
you got like a thousand dollars at 11
and then it bounces up from there
maybe my numbers are wrong but like so
for example in my bank in my bank the
the twenty let's call it five percent
can we okay okay so five over two is a
three spread three okay percent of 36
000 right this is what you're making
yes
have you actually done the math on that
no okay it's a thousand bucks it's a
thousand dollars
okay
so you're not getting rich
right
this is not some big sophisticated Wall
Street play You're parlaying A Credit
Union Savings Account against a car loan
and you made a whole one thousand
dollars you didn't make nothing
but what about the money that is I'm
saying that I'm saving for the house
that twenty five thousand dollars which
is not included in these numbers that we
talked about that money is being yeah
but your premise is is that your debt
was good debt because you're making so
much money on it and I'm saying that's
laughable
a thousand dollars is a joke you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year that's
not laughable that's a real income
yeah yeah you're you're burning a lot of
brain calories to make a grand
I agree okay that's what I'm saying
and by the way it's the only way to make
that spread is if you had 36 Grand in
savings which you don't and so it's
actually less than that you're you're
new to this and you kind of walked into
this and we're abusing you but I'm but
I'm trying to make the point uh just as
lovingly as I can okay so here's the
thing
um if I woke up in your shoes having
done all the stupid butt things I've
done in my life Jason which by the way
everything you've done is brilliant
compared to some of the stupid butt
stuff I've done so that's how I learned
all of this was from experience having
done stuff the wrong way if I woke up in
your shoes my son is close to your age
and he came in he sat down and said Dad
this is my situation based on what you
know about money and based on the fact
that tens of millions of people come to
you for advice on how to handle money
what would you tell me to do if you're
my son here's what I would tell you to
do sell your condo pay off your car
today use all the money you can scrape
together after that above your emergency
fund as your down payment on your new
home and get married as soon as possible
that's what the old man that's what the
old man would tell you and he just did
okay and you hear where that comes where
that comes from is your largest wealth
building tool is your income
it's and you've been trying to find an
angle on this car you're trying to find
an angle on this uh condo and and you're
trying to figure out a way that all this
stuff is smart you make really good
money combined with your new spouse
you're going to make really good money
if the two of you will lean into that
wonderful income and quit giving it to
Banks
you're going to turn into a lot of money
that's where we that's what we want for
you Jason and so every time we answer a
question on this show it's because we
love you guys and we want you to win
and we're going to get right up in your
grill because we love you and let me
show you the math on that Jason just to
show you what your life could be and
it's going to be a lot more peaceful and
a lot less complicated you sell that
condo you're probably going to walk away
with about 100 Grand you take all the
cash you have and you pay off the car
today that's going to still leave you
with seven Grand and so yeah yeah 25 and
24.
emergency fund no condo to worry about
and you have a down payment for your
first primary residence and it's going
to be a whole lot more than you got
today yeah it's gonna be close to 100
Grand and you can be back to investing
in real estate later on down the road
what can you do with cash with cash but
um the the thing you that people do is
and
here's what I want everybody else out
there to listen to here's what we just
did and I had to learn to do this
because I'm a math nerd math nerds do
what Jason did and I used to do it all
the time okay I'm making I'm only paying
1.99 and I'm making 5 to 11. okay that's
great
until you actually multiply it by the
number of actual dollars
and then it becomes
like you can buy a Happy Meal right yeah
and so all of your sophisticated
gyrations end up being a mathematical
joke because what nerds do is we look at
the spreads and all the stuff and we we
never fail to look we always fail to go
all the way to the end result
and the end result is not much money
for all this generation and when you
actually do the actual dollars coming
out of all your bull crap techniques
that somebody taught you on Tick Tock or
whatever then you know when you actually
run the actual dollars out and then you
factor in Risk you've not you know it's
dumb it ends up just being dumb well and
that car is a depreciating asset yeah
and so it's going down in value as you
hang around that 36 Grand in debt and so
that makes it even more laughable as a
healthy debt and so here's the other
thing that backs this up the when we
studied 10 167 millionaires the number
of millionaires that we interviewed that
said you know I borrowed money on my car
at a low interest rate and I put it into
my credit union in a CD
and that's how I became a millionaire
the number of them that answered the
question how did you become a
millionaire using that technique was
precise out of ten thousand one hundred
sixty seven the number that did it that
way was precisely zero
none of them did that
the number of them that became wealthy
by leasing their cars
none of them
did that the number of them that used a
whole life life insurance policy to
build wealth precisely zero
none of them said I got rich and it was
freaking whole life that's what did it
not one of them said that
they all expressed regret about cars and
rip-off financial products as being the
things that held them back they would
have been millionaires sooner
and going into that and credit cards and
going on a trip they couldn't afford
when we asked them about their financial
mistakes they always outlined the things
that regular people do all the time and
strut around and act like they got
airline miles on my card
precisely the number of millionaires
that we met that said Dave you know made
it all with my airline miles precisely
zero
so the data from actual millionaires not
your broke freaking frat brother tells
you otherwise
[Music]
if you love the show and you want a
deeper dive on your money Journey we've
got a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsey personality co-host of
the smart money happy hour and host of
The George camel
big time hit on YouTube the George
Campbell show that's camel with a K he's
a Ramsey personality and he's going to
be answering your financial questions
along with me this hour the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five we'll answer your life
questions as well it's what we do here
Tom is in Dayton Ohio hi Tom how are you
hey what's up
property to leave to my daughter's
grandkids when they get older and
I was wondering if you thought that was
a good idea or not
you gonna pay cash for it yeah you got
plenty of money
what'd you do what were you doing for a
living
I ever made in my life
was about 55 000 a year doing one and
it's doing about the same thing and
we're both retired now what did you do
for a living what was your career
uh basically a handyman
did that my whole life and in just
saving money at 55 000 a year got you
six million bucks yep and it was it was
even more than that before 2008 that
wiped out about I think about two and a
half million it took 10 11 years to
recoup that back again but so you got a
lot in real estate
I I don't have any real estate except
for the home that we're living in that's
paid off and so what'd you do did you
invest it all into
retirement accounts
yeah
how much is the land
no no the land you want to buy you say
it's a half million
won't spend because our financial guy
told me we would never run out of money
if we went to a nursing home for both of
us we should be able to live to be like
99 or something in those
and still not run out of that money so
I'm thinking if the market does take a
correction here
wouldn't it be wise to have something in
like some farmland and lease it to a
farmer and he's paying
ran on the property and making enough to
pay the taxes on it yeah Farmland as an
as an Roi
uh in terms of you know it's it's an
alligator it eats money it doesn't make
money
um you know you can't lease it to a
farmer enough to justify the investment
uh if you were going to do that you buy
income producing property
um you know as far as an investment goes
but you're wanting something uh because
you just like some dirt and you want to
leave some dirt to your kids and
grandkids and the only problem with that
so what are you thinking about spending
on this dirt
well
maybe a million
two or million like 100 acres and right
now it's going for about ten thousand an
acre would go higher
if you go to the higher price land it's
basically a big flat piece of land
no Hills so I'm looking at
Southeast Ohio you actually want you
want some hills right
yeah I want some hills but I don't want
it all in woods either because that
doesn't grow anything except trees yeah
I don't think you're buying this for
what it grows you're buying this for
what it'll go up in value over time and
for the joint enjoyment of going to the
family farm
okay yeah I bought a piece of Farmland
in 08 when everything went down
um that I got a really nice deal on and
I've added a few acres to it from
Neighbors over the years and uh it makes
me absolutely no money every year
but I have a really good time going out
there and shooting and hanging out with
the grandkids and they play in the creek
and and we went out there this winter
and took dragged them up the hill in the
four-wheeler and they rode down in the
sleds and you know so really important
stuff that made absolutely no money
right so that but so my point is this is
kind of a family toy
but you can afford a family toy
of a half a million when you got six
million or 700 000 if you got six
million but I really wouldn't I don't
think you need to justify it with what
you're what you're going to make on it
because you're not going to make
anything on it in your lifetime they're
going to run sell it and double their
money someday double your money someday
but or triple it but but you know you're
not you're not gonna see it
no I just kind of like to maybe go out
on some Bush Hog or
yeah it's real therapeutic I went and
cut down a whole bunch of crap the other
day with my bushel it's really
therapeutic it just destroys everything
it's awesome yeah
yeah so I guess Tom look at it this way
I want you I want you to go do it I just
it's a but I don't want you to justify
it I want you to justify it because if
you took a half a million dollars and
set it in the middle of your floor and
set it on fire your life is not going to
change
so you can afford a half million dollar
toy
No Nonsense
I've never wasted money on going to a
lot of restaurants I I do my own changes
you're in wasting money on anything
you're amazing I mean it's pretty
freaking incredible I think you ought to
enjoy it time to spend some of it but
think about it this way you spent half a
million that still leaves you with four
and a half five million can you live off
that 10 million no you'll be okay in
seven years it'll double anyway
I don't think you're going to spend much
of it beyond that yeah so I think you're
doing this for a great reason and I'm
actually your grandbabies
15 months right now so I figure in
another 4
another two or three years they can help
you drive a tractor or the bush all gone
well they're driving these little
electric cars around here they're 18
months I mean we're not putting them on
tractor right now but I mean this is
it's good for them I mean he'll have
that memory of riding with it I was out
there digging with the skid steer
digging up holes of the day with my
three-year-old in my lap yeah and um you
know so he may not remember anything
else but remember Papa Dave and digging
a hole well I'm pretty sure Charles
Rachel's he's already obviously
absolutely no other talents to dig a
mean hole
that's something I remember nothing else
about the old man but he was a hole
digging pool you know people paid good
money to have big holes Doug Dave you
might have a second career if this
doesn't work out you never know bush
hogging and hole digging yeah that would
be me they don't call him Dave bush hog
Ramsay for nothing around these parts oh
it's too fun hey I I got memories like
that on my grandpa you know and uh the
first time I got to and I was a city kid
I mean I grew up in the suburbs
beginning to go to his farm and driving
his tractor and I'm 10 11 years old and
he let me go out driving out through the
middle of the field I guess there wasn't
anything out there I could hurt but I'm
just putting yourself you know there you
go except myself yeah the seat belt
probably wasn't working I doubt the
airbag was working but what do I know
yeah and they I didn't wear a helmet
either so there's a lot of shocking
things in there I don't think you could
get away with that today
I probably got a callus too doing it you
never know it could have happened it
made you the man you are yeah you never
know made him Dave bush hog Ramsay
you're amazing Tom six million bucks
making 55 000 bucks as a handyman don't
you people tell me it can't be done oh
and he didn't inherit it you stupid
anarchists this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services is your to-do list too
long whether it's a simple repair or a
whole list of Home Improvements Mr
handyman's experienced professionals are
here to make your home work for you
visit neighborly.com to find expert home
service providers including a locally
operated Mr Handyman near you today's
question comes from Kyle in Utah he
writes I know you recommend paying for
things with cash or a debit card but how
do you feel about digital payment
options like Apple pay Zell and venmo
it's easy for me to just pay with my
phone but it almost feels like play
money at this point should I stay with
what's convenient but a little harder
for me to track with digital payment or
what's more cumbersome and takes more
time to deal with with pulling our cash
and splitting everything up feels like I
can't win either way
ah the classic Millennial problem Dave
stuck between a rock and a Digital hard
place here
this is difficult
but this is true I've been seeing these
videos where people feel like when it's
digital or it's on a gift card there's
so many ways they don't feel the pain at
purchase and so I love that he's asking
this question because he's recognizing
this he's self-aware that this is a
problem for him
but he's saying you know with digital
payments I do see that it's easier to
spend it's even more frictionless I mean
apple pays tagline is cashless made
effortless they know that they'll get
you to spend more if you can just double
tap on your phone and hold it near
reader you don't even need to pull the
card out anymore
so that's pretty wild and I know we're
seeing higher levels of buy now pay
later and all these debt issues but when
it comes to digital payments here's my
take if you are doing a zero-based
budget and you are aware of what you're
spending and you've allocated all that
it's okay if you do Apple pay instead of
pulling out your debit card but what
he's saying is he knows that he's
spending more and he feels it less
yeah and you know the MIT study that's
classic is that when you spend actual
cash
like hundred dollar bills with like you
know president's faces on it and stuff
right when you lay that down on the
table and the cashier picks it up
and they hand you your item that it
activates the pain centers of your brain
your brain says oh crap
I don't have that money anymore
when you use a digital transaction even
a debit card your brain does not
activate it doesn't it doesn't show that
the pain centers are not activated
meaning that you're not emotionally
registering the fact that you're
spending money consequently
uh you spend more
the less friction there is now all
marketers know this
every one of us that have a web store
anyone of any sophistication anyway we
are constantly measuring anything that
causes you any kind of problem anytime
we make you click one more time we lose
a bunch of you
and you don't close the sale you abandon
the cart
and I have to make it super easy the
easier we make it the more of our stuff
you buy all of us that have a web store
know that and so the ultimate example of
course is as you said I think the the
newest ultimate example before this it
was Amazon Prime because you can just
you know you just push a little yellow
button that's very the even the color
has been tested we've tested different
colors on submit
on an order and different colors cause
you to buy more oh if it's green button
if it's a red button and yellow and with
different products it's not the same
color even wow sometimes it's a
different color with a different product
but that's how detailed we get into your
how easy are we making it on your
emotions to where you just don't feel
the knife as it goes in right
you know that that's what some marketers
are doing it okay this is what how it
really works in the digital world so
Amazon Prime you don't you don't have to
you don't have to enter your card number
you don't have to enter any shipping
information you don't have to click here
to use same billing information as my
shipping information you don't have to
disavow one of your children you don't
have to do anything you just push a
button and crap shows up on your porch
That's the ultimate in low friction
until
the Apple Store now you walk in grab
something walk out walk out
it's almost like shoplifting
but the Apple phone knows you were there
and registers your purchase
you don't even have to go you don't have
to stand in line at the register there
is no registering that anything occurred
there it is
in your brain and so that's the ultimate
in low friction I mean it feels illegal
almost in terms of I'm just walking here
took something and walked out of the
store I expect something to go beeping
and mark up you copped a ride up on his
unicycle and not tackle me you know I
mean I'm I figure something you know
it's just feel doesn't it I mean oh yeah
you know what I'm talking about I did
this at the Amazon store in Seattle they
have one it's a grocery store or
convenience store where you just said
Amazon does Apple have one too or is it
just Amazon Apple now has one I thought
there's one of each you just walk out
Amazon has them and Apple has them both
it's amazing how that works and so yes
if this is a problem for you you said it
feels like play money that's a red flag
to me that goes we've got to figure out
how to get a hold of this before we
start moving to these more frictionless
payment options I'll give you a
suggestion we've done this during
Financial Peace University for 30 years
when your first start your new life of
controlling your money make it difficult
only add the convenience after you've
reset your habit patterns
where you've if you've lived on a budget
for 9 or 10 or 20 months
successfully and then you want to add
Apple pay back
and I did this for instance when we when
we first started this a long time ago
they didn't have pay at the pump
oh you had to go inside you had to go
inside yeah and um and pay inside now
they would turn it on because in those
days they trusted you you know but you
you know and here's what's interesting
the amount of uproar over gas prices
went down after pay at the pump gas
prices can go to five dollars a gallon
oh people don't think anything about it
because they just stick the cart in pump
a gas up well that looked like a lot of
money oh well and drive off but if you
have to walk inside
like you're walking to the Gallows right
it is frightening you know you have to
walk all the way inside and if you were
to put down a hundred dollars to fill up
your car and they gave you no change
because the pump maxed out at 100 and
quit
you would be ready to string up a
politician
wouldn't you I mean the people will be
out with pitchforks and because there's
no because that's a lot of friction the
brain is going hello hello hello this
crap just got expensive hello hello
hello and and there's none of that none
of those alarms are going off in our
nervous system at all when we do
frictionless purchases so start out and
make it difficult I'll give you an even
more pandemic a more uh uh primitive
version of that when you first start
break your food budget into two
categories
restaurants and groceries
so you don't accidentally spend your
grocery money at the restaurant
it will make you limit your restaurant
purchases and you'll start realizing
that eighty percent of what you spend at
a restaurant is entertainment only 20 is
actual food and you'll realize that when
you separate them when you put it all in
one food budget then you can rationalize
your butt off and just go out to eat all
the time and go on my food budget I
don't have enough for groceries must be
Biden's fault you know no it's your
fault but separating them gives you
friction in that category and causes you
to realize you're spending so it's a
very important discussion we're in such
a convenience culture and one thing that
could help us get back on track with our
finances is making it more inconvenient
on purpose at least until you get a new
habit pattern I use a debit card at the
pump I don't walk inside but I don't
need to worry about Sharon said last
night she goes over at the lake I was
going to go fill her car up and she goes
well how much is gas over there and I'm
like
how much I don't know I love that
Sharon's concerned I don't know you have
enough money it's okay is she saying hey
go to this other station it's 10 cents
it's cheap she wants me and I'm like she
goes well I go to Costco at home and I'm
going and how long do you sit in line
she goes well I know what time of day to
go to where there's no line I'm coming
after my own heart this is this is why
you're sharing freaking Ramsay and I'm
not sure she's a legend it's your
legendary that's how she keeps it you
know I do not I'm not concerned about
gas prices anymore that's not arrogant
I'm not out of touch with the public I'm
just not worried about it anymore I
lived like no one else now I'll buy gas
wherever the flip I want I don't think
anything about it right so I got the
room right so there you go and that's
what you're after but at the end but in
the beginning
every coupon every detail everything
until we got our brains reset
permanently in the common sense Groove
this is the Ramsey Show
please
[Applause]
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage Kyle and Tiffany are
with us hey guys how are you hey way
better than we deserve I love it where
do you guys live Dayton Ohio all right
cool how much data have you paid off we
paid off a hundred and fifty seven
thousand dollars all right how long did
that take nine and a half years all
right 157 a nine after what was your
income during that time it was a range
of 20 to 50 000 and we just barely made
it that 50 000 recently wow what do you
all do for a living I am a pharmacy tech
and an I.T coordinator for a Children's
Hospital in Dayton I've nannied over the
course of this journey and I had an
in-home Bakery now I get to stay home
with our boys all right very good so
nine and a half years 157
000 with a fifty thousand dollar topped
income is that your house that is house
and a car payment as well as a little
bit of school you're a hundred percent
debt free that's right I'm looking at
weird people
how old are you weird people we are 31
31 years old with a paid for house
making 50 Grand what's the house worth
oh now it's worth uh almost 250 000 when
we bought it it was 114. gotta love it
yeah Gotta Love It Well Done y'all
that's pretty cool I mean you're the
little train that could yeah you just
kept at it and kept at it and kept at it
and I will say the price the
it went up in value not just because of
the market recently but we also cash
flowed probably 40 50 000 worth of
improvements on the home as well as
other things throughout this journey as
well so we did all that as well as cash
flowing a lot of different projects good
for you guys so how long you all been
married 10 years we just celebrated this
month all right so as soon as you got
married you start yeah so how does I
explain how that happens funny story I
was actually forced to do FPU against my
will I drugged him in he didn't want to
do it but we listened you were forced
against your will then you drug him
against his will who was doing all this
Dragon it gets worse we listened to you
the whole width to our honeymoon that's
that's sad that's where it started we
had a hard drive to the honeymoon and we
said let's throw on some of these CDs
and we just blasted it the whole way
that's after you both got drug in yeah
who drugged who did the dragon my sister
did your sister drug you in you weren't
married yet no and then you said okay
you're coming too if I got to do this
you gotta do it as soon as she said yes
she said now I can start talking to this
guy about fighting is a little bit more
seriously and so she started pushing it
towards me and all she did was ask me to
track my eating out budget for one month
and that changed my mind real quick wow
that was uh that was inside that was a
good way to kind of yeah just get him on
the hook yeah yeah we came home after
the honeymoon and started killing it
just after that boom we're getting Not
Gonna Knock Out the car and get the
house knocked out too yeah we knew it
was going to be a long journey with
income like that but we knew it was
going to be worth it
well you did you you set a goal and
stuck with it that's pretty impressive
I'm just impressed you stuck with
changing the CDs out to get through all
the lessons it's very impressive it was
a lot we had the whole big box in the
back of the car the whole time wow so
how do you stick with it for nine and a
half years most people if they're 21
years old they're going I didn't do
anything 10 years are you kidding me
I'll find another I'll be 31 yeah
ancient uh well to be fair when we first
started it we had the plan to pay the
house off in six years that was going to
be it we had it all planned out
um we got to the point in our mid-20s
where we really sat down and talked
about it and said you know we we want to
do this we want to knock this out and
create a good future for our children
but we've got to have those children so
we decided to reallocate some money
elsewhere and start to work on our
family now we've got two beautiful
little boys but even through all that we
just barely slowed down a little bit and
just killed it as much as possible so we
added three years on but we got two
Perfect boys out of it and I think what
carried us through that 10 years was
teaching FPU there for about three years
and also just like you said The Little
Engine That Could that's kind of what I
said last night that's what got us
through we had that goal and we did not
stop he got weak I was strong and if I
got weak he said no we have a goal and
we stuck to it very cool we knew the
future that was coming whether we did or
whether we didn't so we wanted to uh see
the one where we are debt free well
thanks for recording Financial Peace
University classes that does have the
benefit of you have to do it because if
you don't you're a hypocrite then yeah
you know and you most humans just can't
do that they have to it makes you more
accountable if you're teaching it it's
strange you get more hardcore teaching
it yeah we had five students over that
time to come to us this year and say we
did it we paid off our student loan
we're so happy to hear that for them we
kind of built their own little Community
yeah well you that's what ends up
happening there's because there's a
shared pain a shared Victory a shared
goal and that makes permanent ties
lifetime friends many times and you
can't talk to a lot of people about this
stuff because they get weird they'll
shame you they go I have student loans
you're trying to judge me and you guys
have created this amazing community of
people who want to get better with money
and aren't scared to talk about it yeah
that's pretty cool yeah because I would
have to say yes I am judging you
I've said that a few times Dave couldn't
coordinate classes anymore it's too
awkward yeah I'm just I'm judging you
yes I am that's kind of what I do for a
living yeah so
that is so cool way to go guys I'm so
proud proud of you I got your sister
that brought you to the FPU class has
got to be bouncing off the walls that's
got to be neat yeah she did she keep
with it too yeah all right got the whole
family going yeah I love it way to go
you guys way to go very very proud of
you how's it feel 31 years old it's
amazing two little boys not have any
payments in the world yeah the freedom
is unreal it took us months to uh to
really let it all settle in just every
day look at each other and just smiling
and knowing we're debt free we don't
have to worry about our children
struggling with this or seeing Mom and
Dad going through the stresses of
finances anymore and it's just it's so
great to wake up every day and know that
you don't have to put that on your
children anymore amen it's crazy our
oldest this summer he's he was there he
went to the bank with us he helped us
sign the last check he how old is he
he's six a Hillary he'll remember it
then he set up a homemade ice cream and
lemonade stand this summer he did it
twice and he made 850 bucks
I'm franchising that wow yep that's
impressive they catch incredible they
catch on they really do and when you
change your family tree you do more than
just change the math everything's
changing the spirit everything's
changing in their character and that
six-year-old will remember that yeah
he'll tell his grandkids yeah I was
there today Mom and Dad paid Dad off
yeah I remember back in time we had
these things called Banks yeah that's
what'll happen which piece of paper
going to check how much everyone check
is son yeah that's that's what will
happen you changed it I mean this whole
thing's gonna be new and that's the old
man sitting there as a multi-millionaire
that's pretty cool well done you guys
hey we got baby steps millionaires the
book for you that's where you're headed
for sure Total Money Makeover to give
away to one of your class participants
and another uh membership to Financial
Peace University and give that away and
get somebody in one of your classes you
guys keep teaching keep leading way to
go thank you so much we're so proud of
you Heroes well done very well done all
right bring the kiddos in let's
introduce them and hear their ages
all right what's six-year-old's name
this is Ryan Ryan the 800 ice cream man
Let It Go Ryan and
this is Bradley Bradley is How old uh
he's just about to be two all right way
to go Bradley well done what do you all
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is finding contentment knowing that
you don't have to have what everyone
else has and you can find joy in the
life that you've built and stick into
that goal being kind of looking at a
picture that looks like contentment I'm
about to cry right this is beautiful
yeah this is well done you've got way
more than they have because you got
Financial Peace way to go very very cool
beautiful beautiful Kyle and Tiffany
Ryan and Bradley Dayton Ohio 157
1000 paid off car and house they're
officially weird people nine and a half
years it took them making 20 to 50 000
they're 31 years old a hundred percent
debt free house and everything hear me
people this can be done these guys are
dropping a mic on you right now you
gotta love it count it down guys let's
hear a debt free scream ready three two
one we're dead
[Applause]
that is how it's done you know what's
weird I didn't hear one complaint gripe
excuse I mean they could have blamed
everyone and everything as to why
they're not where they need to be
financially and they just decided nah
we're gonna do this anyways you don't
hear that from people who are Victors
you hear that from people that are
victims yeah when you're a Victor you
don't need you know excuses are of the
past that you got to put those in the
rearview mirror we're doing it anyway I
know but we're doing it anyway I know
but we're doing it anyway I know but
we're gonna do it anyway this is how
they think that's how people are
unstoppable at that point beautiful
absolutely beautiful family I love it
yes this is why I come down here every
day this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
buying Market but there's a way you can
get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Christopher is in
Bangor Maine hi Christopher welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey how are you guys great man what's up
so I have a question
um first of all I'm about 25 years old
I'm 25 I have no debt and I have about
13 000 in a brokerage fund and a total
stock market 500 index
I also have 15 400 in savings and I just
opened a Roth IRA with about 1200 in it
and because I don't own a house and I
have no debt I feel like I can invest
more than just maxing out my Roth IRA so
my first question is do you think that I
should take the tax up front and take my
money online brokerage to put it in the
Roth or if I should keep it in say safer
a house and also what I can do with
extra income um how I can invest that
what's your income
um right now it's a little sporadic I'm
a deckhand on a boat it could be
anywhere from two to two grand to 3 500
a month what are you making a year
um
a with this maybe 30 or so
okay I should make a 30 000 a year are
you living on the boat
no no I live in uh my own uh housing
okay
all right so what was the purpose of the
brokerage account what was your goal
with that
um so that was actually something that
my father stood up for me when I was 18
and of course I didn't really understand
it
um and so for a little while I was just
funding it until I kind of realized hey
I need to understand what's going on
without just blindly funding an account
that's smart that's good to be
understanding what you're putting money
into and why and so that's that's the
heart of my question is figuring out
what are your next goals you have no
debt uh you have some money in savings
that's good that's we're going to call
that your emergency fund and so your
next step would be would be to invest 15
of your income into those tax advantage
retirement accounts
okay so I'm not seeing a need to fire
sale liquidate The Brokerage immediately
you could use your future income to
fully fund that Roth uh even then do you
have any other ways to increase your
income long term
um can't think of anything off to the
top of my head right now I think you're
a pretty Frugal dude you live pretty low
because you're living you're living well
under a thirty thousand dollar income
and still saving money it's impressive
so I mean normally I talk to somebody
like you they call me up with a credit
card debt a car payment and everything
else and you've managed to stay away
from all that congratulations well done
so 15 of 30 000 would be eight thousand
okay okay it would be nine thousand but
you could fully fund your eight thousand
Roth right so fully fund your Roth out
of your income you can sit down with a
smartvester pro if you want to click a
smartvester at
ramseysolutions.com that'll tell you who
we recommend in your area they can set
it up or monthly you put into a Roth and
you fully fund it once you can fully
fund it over time I don't think you have
to cash out the brokerage to fund it I
think you can fund it out of your income
this coming year at 25 if you'll do this
from 25 to 65 you have plenty of money
you'll be a multi-millionaire if you say
15 of your income
from 25 to 65 you'll be a
multi-millionaire okay if you don't do
anything else but that and uh even at
making 30 grand so if you fully fund a
Roth you'll be a multi-millionaire
um at uh 65. so we talked to a 70 year
old who never made more than 55 and he's
got six million bucks yeah so it can be
done that's exactly right and you know
by the way folks Washington Post is
reporting Fidelity uh the mutual fund
family is saying that 401k millionaire
Club grew thanks to a stock market rally
um George read over this this is good
this is pretty wild so new data from
Fidelity found the number of employees
with 401k balances over one million
dollars Spike 26 percent in the second
quarter so now there's 378 000 of those
accounts compared to under 300 000 by
the end of 2022 and the average balance
in these 401ks was 1.5 million dollars
and here's the key they stuck to it
these are people who contributed
steadily to their plans e even when the
stock market took a heart clutching dive
it says they've seen that payoff in
their account balances and this is
something that you know we've been
preaching to you've been preaching it
for 30 years now but just stay on the
roller coaster and you won't get hurt
well and here's the thing you know when
the news reports that the stock market
is up
never
did you guys know the stock market's up
since the first of the year 15 percent
if you put in ten thousand dollars or
five thousand dollars or a thousand
dollars 500 million whatever at the
first of the year you would have made 15
on your money in an S P 500 which is a
stock market index right it's measuring
the growth of the stock market
and if it made 15 on your money but you
know the news is
inflation's 9.6 percent there's supply
chain problems and Hillary the hurricane
not the woman hit California
I mean this is it that's a good caveat
yeah we need to be hurricane no emails
were deleted in this message but yeah so
the um wow I mean this is 15 in one year
you know from the first January one to
today have you heard a single news
report telling you this well I got to
give it to the Washington Post Fidelity
reporting millionaire Club is up right
the number of workers with a million
dollars or more in their 401ks hit an
all-time high
and the eores are still out there Dave
you know what the new line is now well a
million dollars isn't enough anymore
Dave it's more than you got Winer
that one's my favorite won't get you as
far as it used to it won't it'll get you
further than you are
but these people aren't retired whining
and they've got 1.5 million they're
still on the journey yeah and here's
what the interesting thing is you run
all these formulas and theories and
stuff I was meeting with the every
dollar team the other day and they're
working on a formula for retirement
calculator we're going to build into
that thing and I was just just don't do
it like the financial industry because
the financial industry runs a bunch of
hypothetical crap that never actually
occurs
what actually really occurs see if all
if I give you some examples I can say
for example okay if you invest a hundred
dollars a month from age 25 to age 65 in
a decent growth stock mutual fund that
average 12 percent you'd have one
million 172 000. that's an example
well me and warriors 32 000 has done
enough and you didn't inflation adjust
that and and and you know is that CGR
what kind of math what kind of freaking
nerd cares you got a million dollars
more than your dad
who had nothing
shut your butt up and save money hello
this is the point so quit trying to our
purpose here is to get you to actually
do this stuff not run theoretical think
tanks
the doing it is the pit difference you
know most of the people we interviewed
that made me Had a Million Dollars they
they can't tell you what a CGR is they
didn't sit and ring their little nerd
analytical hands over whether how do we
what kind of inflation rate do we use
because in the last 10 years prior to
Biden it was 2.6 percent do we use a
post Biden inflation rate or a
pre-bidden inflation rate or do we go
back 72 years since the CPI started and
it's 4.2 percent what do we do with our
good God you sound just would you just
shut up and put some money in your
account you haven't even mentioned
expense ratios yet Dave I left those out
too and 12 B1 fees like I don't know
they're there because I don't care if
they're there well the people that
invest are the ones that have money the
ones that don't invest because they get
paralysis of the freaking analysis don't
do anything they have no money
so that's the beauty of this young man
Brent oh yeah see he didn't need them
he's working on a on a boat
he's working on a boat in Maine hello
making thirty thousand he's going to be
a multi-millionaire
because George told him how to do it and
he's gonna actually go do it and he's
not trying to impress his friends with a
giant car payment well and
he didn't he didn't need some kind of
hypothetical
you know 19 variable adjusted
rationalization
to learn to be an investor he thought
you know my dad got me started with this
it's probably a good idea that I do some
more of it well way to go Brent you got
something called common sense they got
it in Maine they got it in Tennessee and
they got it in a few of the other states
out there you can look around you'll
find them get you some oh my gosh but
the study found that the average
investor in this millionaire study they
were just average they weren't prodigies
they weren't doing anything fancy and I
guarantee you they don't even know what
a 12 B1 fee is and this article ends
with this the majority of Savers stayed
the course and did not make significant
changes to their retirement savings Oh
you mean they didn't time the market you
mean they didn't worry about the dollar
being sniper shot by a new
whole new currency coming out of China
and Brazil we're all going to hell I'm
taking my money out right now no they
just kept investing just merrily alone
stop naturally merrily merrily along
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships thank you for
joining us America George Campbell
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
he is the co-host of smart money happy
hour one of our more popular podcasts on
the old Ramsay Network check it out he
and Rachel have a lot of fun on that
show and they even give you some
information that's useful so try it out
you'll like both of them and also the
George camel with a k
YouTube program is uh exploding yeah
faster than even we imagined and we knew
he was a star so check it out these are
my co-hosts today phone number here
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Bob is in Boston hey Bob welcome to
the Ramsay show
George hope you both are well we are sir
how can we help looking for some
guidance today so so after following
your baby steps for many years and our
kids are through college at this point
my wife and I are aligned on on wanting
to purchase a second home
it's a little complex for me is uh she's
talking about us some that I'm not
necessarily comfortable with uh and I am
looking to slow down in a couple of
years I'll probably work part-time in a
couple within a couple of years or so so
I I need help you know I want I want to
please her I want to do the right thing
by her
um but I think I need some help getting
comfortable with the kind of numbers
that she's talking about
okay
uh what do you make
um I make just under 700 000 a year
what's your net worth
about eight million dollars okay what do
you do for a living
I'm in finance way to go Bob Well's done
man you are impressive that's a very
cool thing so excited for you
congratulations thank you so what is she
wanting to spend on this home
something like 200 million dollars
which is what's your current residence
worth
uh about five hundred thousand dollars
your current residence is worth five
hundred thousand
yes and your second home will be two and
a half million well that's a lot of
whack
where's the second I hear you okay well
number one man here's my rule of thumb
on second homes they're they're I I've
got I've got them okay they're toys
and so they need to be a number one you
got to pay cash for them or you don't do
them uh you're asking the Ramses so
you're in finance you're obviously have
done very well you're going to do what
you're going to do but this is my rule I
would never do it unless you paid cash
number one number two their toys meaning
they don't produce an income it's not a
great category of real estate to invest
in because Resort real estate is the
only type of real estate that's more
volatile than being a developer these
are the two places you can lose your
butt the most in real estate so for
instance I've got a lake house one year
it's worth uh two million dollars one
year it's worth four million dollars and
then the next year it's worth two
million again just I mean they coming it
comes and goes and comes and goes and
comes and goes you follow me so
um then the the second rule on toys lake
houses
um second homes whatever we want to call
them here is that if
they're not going to be income producing
uh and and so it needs to be a small
enough percentage of my net worth that
we could stomach it if we lost it
um because you're taking this much money
offline it's no longer earning any money
it will appreciate in value over time
probably
most likely but that's not why we're
buying it it's not an income producing
asset it's you know it's it's a capital
gains asset so
um you know if you're buying it to
speculate on then don't buy it uh
because you're buying it for a second
home my lake house is not for sale it
will be sold someday after I'm gone but
it's not for sale for any price I keep
up with values just because I'm a real
estate nerd but it's not for sale and so
that's what you're doing here you're
taking that much money offline and that
feels like a large chunk offline out of
8 million to me
that's the way I feel too
um I was thinking a million and I was
going to go with it
yeah yeah is there some compromise here
or is she dead said it's got to be this
one oh yeah oh no no no they would
definitely be compromised there I say I
think her view is Hey listen we're not
getting any younger we have this we have
this pot of money we've always lived
below our means if we're gonna do it
let's do it and let's let's just go for
it yeah I mean that'd be 12 of your net
worth
is tied up in a toy and that's that's
pretty heavy but that's doable
um for me I I you know I had a million
out of eight million right and the good
news is how old are you
52. okay so how much longer are you
gonna work making 750.
[Music]
three years
okay
and um
and then you're going to be living out
of your net worth
yes yeah and so
um you're gonna slow its growth because
right now its growth is compounding
right so you're gonna be spending some
of that to live because you're used to a
decent lifestyle I would assume making
750. then and you shouldn't be denied
that I'm okay with that I mean so yeah
that that's another because I think the
description if this was me talking to
Sharon I'd say honey what that means is
we're going to have to it would trim our
monthly
income down because we're taking a chunk
we're taking a third of our a fourth of
a third of our uh net worth offline it's
no longer creating income for us
and saying I'm uncomfortable with that
number for that reason because I want to
keep our income steady so we don't have
to think about we can do anything we
want to do with a good income because I
mean if you've got 7 million working for
you you can still make six seven hundred
thousand dollars a year off of that
right
right that's right yeah and so and
perpetuation I can I bet you can and so
um that that's that's what I want to set
up for you so I think that's the way you
talk to her about is I don't want to cut
that six or seven hundred thousand to
four or five hundred thousand because we
got so much tied up in a second home
I think that makes uh a lot of sense and
I like I like that approach I think she
I think she'll be open to that yeah
um
she just saw something she liked and she
knows you've worked your butt off and
she wants to enjoy it before it's gone
yeah I'll go along with her on that you
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else that puts
us on her team right until we look at
the ratios and the ratios are bothersome
that's right that's right yeah
well listen I appreciate your guidance
here I value your opinion so uh thank
you both very much oh you're an
incredible incredible dude well done
great problem I'm sitting back here
going this is a real problem don't get
me wrong but this is a great problem to
have this is the problem you have if you
follow our advice
if you do the stuff we teach you're 32
years old and you work the baby steps
you're Bob
at 52 or 62.
struggling with how much
or two million into your second home
hello
this is the but you notice what he's
living in
half a million he's not living in an 8
million dollar house making 700 000.
notice the big difference Hollywood
notice that
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John deloney has a brand new book
coming out called building a non-anxious
life if you pre-order the day you'll get
75 dollars in free bonus items uh nearly
half the population reports their lives
are affected by anxiety stress or
burnout it's everywhere but here's the
thing anxiety is not the problem
the problem is anxiety is an alarm Bell
that's going off telling you that we
feel unsafe disconnected unhealthy our
finances are in turmoil our
relationships and that causes anxiety
anxiety is the symptom and Dr John walks
you through the six daily choices to
recognize and break free from a life
that is spinning spinning spinning
out of control
yeah
pre-order today building a non-anxious
life
twenty dollars at
ramseysolutions.com George Campbell
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
Brent is with us Brent is in Charlotte
North Carolina Hi Brent welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call sure
man what's up
yeah
um I am currently in babysitter too with
my wife we just found you guys about a
month or so ago and we've been reading
The Total Money The Total Money Makeover
book and it's really changed my whole
life on how I look at money because
um I'm a generation third business owner
not with this business I'm currently
owning but
um we're currently in baby step two and
um we've had some changes to our
business this past fourth quarter
um well for you know starting in the
fourth quarter of last year and my wife
and I are trying to put a budget
together personally
um to pay off our debt and everything
like that we have our thousand dollar
emergency fund but trying to come up
with the income for me and my business
to put towards our budget has been a
challenge for my wife and I and we're
just trying to figure out
um how to set the proper income for my
business I've tried to look at my life
and kind of see how much money I need to
bring in to take care of our basic needs
but it's a very challenge because our
business has took a step back and it's
put more responsibility on me
um to do the actual work before I had
technicians um you know doing our work
for us and um I was able to run it from
uh you know an owner perspective and uh
it's just been a challenge for me in my
life and I just wasn't sure
um how you could uh get a budget number
so we can start paying off our debt and
babysit you
when we get to end of 2023 and you look
at your p l on the business what will be
your net profit
uh we lost money last year no 2023.
um 2023 we will be lucky to break even
how are you how are you and does your
wife have a job
yes yes my wife sent in um house
speakers so she owns a bakery and I own
an electrical business why are you only
breaking even
because I've probably took on more
um people last year than I I probably
should have and we kind of put us in a
situation where I was making sure they
were taken care of and not paying myself
like I should
there's not paying you there's a
difference between paying yourself and
not making a profit
you can make a big old Harry profit and
not take any of it home leave it in the
business
but you're not making any profit which
means the people that work for you are
in danger of losing their job because
you're in danger of closing
correct and so you're not doing the
people that are there a big favor by not
making a profit it is required of you as
a business owner to continue to make a
profit to stabilize the business for the
good of the team
and that may mean that some of the team
needs to leave so the rest of the team
gets to survive
yeah yeah absolutely I mean we do great
work we're making no you don't you don't
make enough money to eat
you're not making a profit why are you
not making a profit because you kept too
much payroll
that's what you told me
yeah too much payroll and I have a big
heart and I try to help people and I
guess that it's put myself in it what
are you doing to help people what do you
mean
like
um
part for the younger generation going
into the trade industry and so I bring
on young people and train them and I've
started more businesses than
I'm willing to admit because I'm great
at being a electrician and I'm great at
you know I've read the book uh emath and
it really opened my eyes up to being a
technician owning a business and I'm
working on I'm following entree
leadership
a lot of images where I'm struggling
no no I just started I just started okay
you know um yeah yeah thank you because
we teach people to make a profit there
um yeah yeah because you can't continue
you can't continue the ministry that
your heart is pulling you to you can't
you you want to serve the people on your
team and you want to bring people on
your team and give them a shot and you
want to introduce them to the trades and
you have a heart to do all of that you
are going to lose the ability to do that
because you're trying to run this
without making a profit so you have got
to make some difficult decisions to be
able to continue to do the ministry that
you want to do
gotcha so you can't say I'm unwilling to
tell anyone no or send anyone home for
the good of the organization and blame
that on a big heart because ultimately
your big heart is going to not get
anything done
yeah and I mean we were doing great
until last year and we took a step back
and honey you told me you lost money
last year and this year you're going to
break even that's two years you've made
no money this is not a hobby it's a
business
sure you have to make the business
decisions to get it profitable and that
means some of your people that you
brought on as as projects need to go
home
for the good of everybody else and for
the good of future project people if you
want to help so and so and be bring a
young person on and and help them you
know come out of prison and get them
going or whatever it is you want to do
you want to help people and you want to
use the business do that please for
God's sakes do that that you're the kind
of man we want running a business out
there but you have got to say you got to
have make hard decisions to be able to
make the good decisions
you can only give out of the Overflow
and right now you don't have any
overflow yeah you're struggling to make
ends meet absolutely your job first is
take care of your family
first yeah and that's what's really
opened my eyes by you know starting with
Entre leadership and starting with you
know Finance for Peace University I've
really opened my eyes up that my family
need to be the a major priority and
that's why I mean I have made some
decisions lately to turn this around
because I mean we do great work I just
gotta I don't I don't I'm not
questioning the quality of your work
Brent yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm just
saying that
um you know when I first started in
business I thought for here's an example
of something that's a little different
but it falls in the same bucket
I thought by not confronting people
inside of our organization that we're
doing things wrong that I was being nice
because I'm Southern
and being nice is what you do it's
called passive aggressive
right we're always nice we say bless
your heart we'll slit your throat and
say bless your heart we're Southern but
we're always nice right I always wanted
to be nice I always wanted to be a nice
Christian man and what I finally figured
out is is that by not confronting
people's misbehavior I was actually
allowing the business to be torn apart
from the inside and and I was staying
angry all the time on my drive home at
their misbehavior that I had never even
told them was misbehavior this is
completely my fault and so we adopted a
new slogan here's our new slogan is
about it's about 20 years old now
to be unclear is to be unkind
so that's my version of being nice
but with strength I'm going to be very
clear because to otherwise is to be
unkind and you're being unkind to the
Future people that you want to help with
this business because you're being too
kind too nice you're being nice instead
of kind you're being nice to the current
people instead of the other yeah and
your family is also part of this and
we're trying to get out of debt and so
we need to get our income up yeah so if
I'm you I'm going I can make 70 grand as
a electrician or make zero dollars
running this business you need some
money and so it might be time to reset
this business and how it's structured
and see if you can get a profitable fast
and if you can't you probably need to go
work for somebody until you can get your
act together and get there because only
the strong can help the weak sir
you know starving kids don't feed
starving kids projects don't help
projects you're now a project you've
turned yourself into one this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Jason
and Kendall are with us hey guys how are
you we're doing fantastic day of thanks
honored to have you where do you guys
live we are from Waukesha Wisconsin all
right welcome to Nashville and all the
way here to do a debt free scream how
much did you pay off
784 dollars love it how long did this
take four years five months and eight
days ah I love it very good and your
range of income during that four years
and five months 200 to 350 000 combined
very cool what do you all do for a
living we're in sales uh I am uh I sell
a life-saving uh Healthcare equipment
and I'm in cyber security sales ah very
good two great businesses well done good
what kind of debt was the 351 there was
a phone there was a car a credit card a
lake house slash Cottage and our home
wow
Wyler people a hundred percent free
[Music]
way to go guys I think very cool very
cool how old are you two I'm 41. and I'm
38. and what's the house worth
we bought it for 300 and it's now worth
450 to 500 000. very cool how much in
your retirement savings 850 000.
talking to millionaires with a paid for
house and Lake cottage I love it way to
go you guys thank you and at 41 years
old and 38 wow oh very good excellent
baby steps millionaires well tell us the
story what happened four and a half
years ago that got all this started and
uh made the whole family go into a tizzy
and now it worked well it started a
little bit before that we I found the
podcast and I said Jason we should
listen to this because we were feeling a
little out of control but we listened
for like a month and we're like ah we've
got it under control we can pay these
credit cards off every month we're doing
fine and then in November of 2018 Jason
was laid off from his job right ahead of
the holidays and we realized we really
were a short period of time away from
not being able to handle what we had
going and it scared it scared us so bad
that we we decided okay let's go back to
that podcast we were listening to Scared
Straight Scared Straight yep and then um
what really solidified it for us is a
year later Jason was laying it off again
but at that point
it was a rough patch it was a blessing
in disguise though like it like that
that job that he rushed into that that
in 2018 was it was a great job
financially but terrible emotionally for
him so it was a true blessing and then
in 2019 I was able to say like let's
let's take time you find a job that you
are really going to love and he's still
there today so so yeah so that's you're
making bank too yeah doing well yep and
then in April of 2020 we had the
opportunity to finish baby step two and
you know things were uncertain well
there's some timing we're like well
maybe we should just patent down the
hatches and and prepare for a storm but
we just decided to go into the storm and
pay off and do baby step two be done
with it love it yep and then to
celebrate baby step two we got a mini
Goldendoodle and we named him Ramsay
David oh wow is it the middle name
Ramsay David is yeah David's his middle
name yeah dog can have middle names so
when he goes in the floor yeah Ramsay
Davis
my wife says we joke that he gives
terrible Financial advice because he's a
dog
hey that dog is debt free he's doing
better than most Americans I'm sure yep
and and then from there we pivoted into
let's let's pay off the house and how
cool would it be to stand here and be
fully debt-free when we stood here
a lot wow powered on through good for
y'all very good stuff amazing so were
the girls a part of this journey I mean
they're old enough they're like seeing
mom and dad go gangbusters on this debt
I mean was it weird for them were they
all in were they calling you guys out
you know what they always pretend that
they don't like it they've had plenty of
uh podcasts uh they heard too much Dave
Ramsey and they like to talk a lot of
smack about it but yeah if you're a
teenager you have to have the eye roll
down oh yeah I see the eye roll come on
let's see it you can do it yeah you got
to have it down you gotta have the eye
roll down it's part of it later on in
life they're like oh yeah actually I was
into that so I try to play cool but I
liked it yeah but yeah anytime they see
a movie where somebody uh uses a credit
card I don't know they're like oh my
gosh I cannot believe that they're in
debt yeah who would have thought Brad
Pitt did that right they've they've
joined us we've LED five rounds of FPU
at our church
um at Bridge Church in Waukesha Waukesha
go Bridge Church
um and they've been there at least come
along a few times to to sit in and you
know help with the kids sometimes and
and even kind of share their story once
in a while so
how hard it is being your kid yeah right
you guys are awesome I'm so proud of you
you're hundred percent free you're
Millionaires and you're 40. how's that
feel
David's phenomenal you know it's we have
a true understanding of what you mean
when you say financial piece it it
allows us to to change what our dreams
are instead of thinking of how are we
going to get out of this we can think of
what are we going to go to how are we
going to get there and we know that we
control our destiny and we can actually
plan on how we're going to do it yeah
amen amen so we're leading one of these
classes you've obviously got a great
example to set in front of them you guys
you say we paid off our house we had
this we got 800 000 savings oh my gosh
look at this this is where you can be
that's got to be very persuasive for
someone in the class that's scared
that's hopeless that's beat down that
doesn't know if they can do it they can
look at you guys and go I think maybe I
can yeah I think when we started doing
FPU I think you know I was a little
afraid of you know how do we share this
like how how honest do we get about
where we're at and where we're going and
we just decided if we're going to do
this if we're going to give
one week a night for nine weeks every
single year we're gonna go all in and be
very open and upfront with everyone in
our class and it's really created this
cool community that we have where they
come up to us and they're like hey guess
what I did we just paid off our car or
here's what we're gonna do next and then
they ask where are you guys at we're
we're just following along this a lot of
them come back to our class and just sit
in and we'll then kind of be the
testimony in that first class to say hey
I did this last year and here's where
we're at now here's what a year can do
oh wow it's really neat that's powerful
yeah they need to be coordinators too
yeah some of them are yeah your
grandparents yeah look at that cow guys
I'm very proud of y'all very cool very
cool so what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt if I think the
key is actually deciding that you're
going to do it not just thinking I wish
I was able to do what I wish I was debt
free deciding that you're going to do it
and you're willing to sacrifice what it
takes to get there yeah and start if you
have started start today because I mean
we started when the girls were like nine
and seven and you know a lot of I felt
like a lot of people told us like you're
gonna miss out on these core years that
you could be taking them places or you
know doing things with them they're
giving them things
and now we're here and we get to just
and they seem they seem fairly well
adjusted yeah I mean it's for teenagers
yes
you didn't kill them after all who knew
who knew yeah way to go guys very proud
of y'all hey we got a baby steps
Millionaire's book to celebrate the fact
that you are uh we've got a Total Money
Makeover book as well that you'll give
to somebody Financial Peace University
membership you can give that to someone
you've obviously done a lot of good
thank you for leading the classes and
for being this huge example for the uh
for the audience out there thank you so
much very cool heroes very cool and uh
we we've uh poked at the girls and and
teenage girls and all that stuff for a
minute here but the truth is that when
they look back years from now they'll
realize how big a hero their mom and dad
are and you guys have changed your
family tree you really have it's pretty
impressive what you've done very very
cool Jason and Kendall Addison and
Amelia from Wisconsin 351
000 paid off house and everything on the
way to being baby steps millionaires at
41 and 38 years old four and a half
years it or four years five months it
took to do that making 200 to 350
through job changes and everything else
they persevered 100 percent debt free
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
I love it well done you guys very well
done this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
Colossians 4 6 let your conversation be
always full of grace seasoned with salt
so that you may know how to answer
everyone C.S Lewis said there are only
two kinds of people those who say to God
thy will be done and those who to whom
God says all right then have it your way
I like that that's a new verse for me I
like that your conversation's seasoned
with assaults you've been known to be
salty in conversation it's been it's
been happening more lately
Shannon is in Virginia Roanoke to be
precise hi Shannon welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call my
pleasure what's up
okay so I'm just kind of like I've heard
about you before like when I was younger
and in my 20s I'm 45 at the moment
um and so I'm just kind of like
rediscovering you I've started listening
to uh budget Christian Mama on tick tock
and so I try to get her lives every
morning and she just talked about how
her and her husband have knocked out all
this debt in like 18 months and
so I don't I mean I have quite a bit of
debt as far as like my car and student
loans and stuff go but as far as like
credit cards and stuff I don't really
have a lot of debt
but I was raised by my mother who was a
single mom but she I didn't know when I
was younger but as I got older just
figuring out that that's pretty much how
she raised us was on credit cards and
I have kind of continued the same cycle
but not so much as far as credit cards
because I've never really had my life
together enough to qualify for the
amount of credit cards that she has
which is probably a good thing
um but I also have not like saved any
money
I have uh how can we best help you today
Shannon
I don't know where to begin so to speak
um I kind of understand the gents of it
but I don't oh no I'm just kind of
looking for some kind of guidance as far
as sure instructor goes well I'll say
this uh the best time to plant the tree
was 20 years ago the next best time is
today yeah and so I you gotta just put
the past behind you and go whatever my
mom did whatever happened in the past
it's over I've got I'm gonna start to
chart A New Path for Shannon and change
the family tree and break those
generational curses so the answer is not
how do I have less credit card debt than
my parents the answer is how do I put
myself in such a financial position that
I can just stop talking about money and
worrying about money
and so that's the goal if we have that
as the Common Ground here we're off to a
good start the next step is to filter
this through the Ramsay baby steps so
you said you're new to this so I'll run
you through them real quick and then I'm
going to gift you something that will go
in depth on this okay
okay thank you so the first step and the
reason this works is because it's one
Focus step at a time we're not doing 17
things at once and trying to keep up
with a bunch of debts so baby step one
is a thousand dollar starter emergency
fund you have a thousand dollars in cash
in the bank account
uh no I have I've started a business in
October too and that's been my main
scariest thing is that I'm afraid of
running it into the ground by the amount
of money that I'm making and it will I
guess continue to just grow so what what
is your income
um as far as my business goes it kind of
fluctuates but I started a house
cleaning business and it averages
um
somewhere around 72 to 74 but it has
gone
mostly it's over seven thousand I mean
over 8 000 closer up to 9 000 every
month every month profit
that is just like see and that I don't
have anything I'm just like transferring
money as I need it so where is this 9
000 going every month
I
I couldn't tell you that's my problem
okay I'm just like mine does your
business have any expenses
well I mean I'd buy like the uh vacuum
cleaners when I first started I got them
on
um I think it is a firm so I'm making
payments on those and I would like to
pay them off
um
my like cleaning supplies and stuff like
that that's really not that much money
it's not nine thousand dollars worth of
expenses
daughter works with me as well I do pay
her
um an hourly but it's only hourly
you're cleaning
your business is cleaning
yes okay okay and you've got two vacuums
on payments
okay all right but other than that
you're not you don't have a ton of
expenses so a lot of this money is free
and clear for you to live on okay
yeah I think that if I can figure out
how to get to where I can like I feel
like I've dug myself in a hole to where
I have slowly tried to get out over the
last couple of weeks and I have done
better this week but I need to figure
out how I can
like just pay myself weekly or whatever
instead of
I need 100 in my checking account let me
transfer it over well that's where the
budget comes in you said you're watching
budgeting videos and you're wanting to
get into this so I'm gonna gift you one
year of every dollar premium to help you
out with this and it's going to help you
make uh give every single dollar a job
because you've got plenty of money it's
just disappearing because you're giving
it to lenders yeah who knows where I'll
eat now I don't know what your lifestyle
is like but we've got to get all of this
in check and start to go we're paying
myself first I'm going to pay these
debts I'm going to put extra on the debt
I'm gonna live off nothing so I can get
myself in a good financial position how
much is the total debt that you have
um my personal debt is somewhere around
000 maybe not quite that high but my
student loans are 20 000. last time I
looked at it it was like 38-ish 39ish
um so my student loans are like 20 000.
my car is 14 something just over 14
000. um and then I have a few little
credit cards uh probably somewhere
around the 5 000-ish Dollar Mark okay
well starting today if you want to build
wealth
a foolproof way is to just stop going
into debt and that means we're cutting
up the cards we're not going to do these
buy now pay later plans if we don't have
the cash to do it we just don't do it
okay yeah you're gonna affirm to never
do a firm again
right
so the next thing you do is you list out
the debts from smallest to largest
balance don't even look at the interest
rate smallest the largest balance attack
the little one with a Vengeance with all
the margin you can muster up from that
nine thousand a month
and that's going to get rid of that
first step really quickly agreed
agreed and you free up a little payment
there don't you so now you can throw all
of that towards the next debt that's the
debt snowball you pick up snow as you go
that's baby step two and so you can do
this if you put them in order baby step
one then baby step two then we're gonna
get to an emergency fund so you never
have to turn to debt again see how that
works when you have six months of
expenses in the bank you don't need
lenders anymore do you
no okay Shannon um just in listening to
you
um you are a a smart person
you're smart enough to do better than
you're doing
because you're living with a fair amount
of chaos not much order there's not much
order no no yeah disorganization and
Chaos adds a lot of stress to your life
so one of the things you can do here is
to
um pretend that I was going to pay you a
hundred thousand dollars a year
and you just went to work for me
and knowing what you know today
about money which is not much okay
you're just getting started you're just
starting your journey but even with what
you know today you are a smart person
you're articulate if I said I'm going to
hire you for a hundred thousand dollars
the first thing I want you to do is go I
got this lady that's got in the cleaning
business over here she's disorganized I
want you over there and get her
organized you could do that you could
get her organized because you're smart
enough to do it your problem is you get
so emotionally stuck in all these
different things and it's flying at you
and you need to I want you to pan back
and step above this and look at it as if
you're managing someone else's stuff
okay emotionally step aside like an
out-of-body experience okay and say all
right I just got hired to straighten up
This Woman's finances and she's a mess
and first thing I'm gonna do is make a
really good detailed list of all my
monthly bills the second thing I'm gonna
do is make a really good detailed list
of all these debts the third thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to open a set
you got a separate checking account for
your business
yes I did start everything right I kind
of did it backwards but I do have
everything separated now okay good yeah
and so now when you move money out of
that business you understand you need to
set tax money aside right
right so you don't get caught in taxes
because that IRS is going to pound your
head next year if you don't do that so
you hang on and Georgia's going to get
you set up with every dollar premium the
folks in the booth will take care of
that for you you're smart enough to do
this you've got to get yourself
organized remove the chaos add order and
follow these steps we'll show you how to
do it you can do this
[Music]
will be back with you before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
foreign
[Music]